all right um let's get started for
today um let's see where are we in the
class we covered a lot already um we
covered thus far all generative models
though models that are built in a way
that you can sample from them to
generate new data similar to your
training data and um often that might be
what you want but often what you want is
actually a model that is just a
pre-train model that you can then
fine-tune for task you care about and
really what you want from that pre-train
model is that it somehow extracts good
representations from your data um the
generative models can do that too um but
you could say why not just purely focus
on getting good
representations um historically the way
people got good
representations was by training
supervised and that was one of the big
things in deep learning that never
happened before in other types of
learning you do supervised learning deep
learning on imag net and turns out the
features that you get from supervis
learning on imet also do well on other
data sets so that was the initial
version of kind of pre-training
pre-train supervised on imag net but
that didn't scale because then people
need to annotate too much data and so
today we're going to look at selfs
survis learning approaches which means
looking at approaches that try to really
focus on the pre-training and get good
representations out and so almost all
the evaluations we'll see today for the
papers that we cover will be along the
lines of after we pre-train we now fine
tune or put a linear classifier on top
of the learn newal Network and see how
well it does with a small amount of data
or modest amount of data very often but
sometimes also with large amount of data
later used um and see how well it does
compared to training from scratch um
I'll cover roughly the first half as I
had mentioned on Ed but I want say in
lecture unfortunately I can't do office
hours I need to go to a Berkeley
fundraising event support our Chancellor
meeting meeting some donors go home put
on a suit and like show up there um um
and talk about AI so I mean it should be
a fun one um but uh it won't be nearly
as detailed AI chats as as we have here
um but uh I'll still be talking about AI
um so I wanted my office hour after
lecture I'll probably even take off
Midway through right when Philip takes
over um but as I said on Ed if you need
wanted to catch me today after lecture
and you really want to catch me soon
drop me an email and we'll find the time
to set a video call probably would be on
on either Friday afternoon so tomorrow
afternoon or on Monday we would do a a
video
call okay so this is an example uh we're
borrowing from Ian Goodfellow the
inventor of Gans from one of his
tutorials and essentially the point is
that good representations matter if you
want to learn a classifier between the
blue circles and the green triangles
it's much easier on the right where
they're already nicely separated just
draw a line between them whereas on the
left you have to to find essentially a
circle between them which is a more
complex thing to learn and to position
correctly what's the difference XY
coordinates versus polar coordinates um
now this is a hand design example but
it's to showcase the notion that if you
can somehow come up with the right
representation either yourself or
through learning it can help you solve a
problem more easily
afterwards um in deep learning the way
this tends to work is that in goes pixel
level things if you just process pixels
raw pixels with a modest amount of
processing you're not getting a whole
lot of uh information out of it um what
we see in these networks is that layer
by layer and they started with
supervised learning where we already saw
this but now today we'll cover cell
supervis learning um early on there
might be Edge detectors then there might
be Circle other shaped detectors and at
some point there might be face detectors
and so forth that emerge inside these
networks and so essentially what's
happening is like
small little units initially get
composed into them bigger and bigger
units that are being recognized in some
more semantically meaningful way inside
the network and again if you had a
network that was pre-trained and already
had a neuron for I don't know face or
for smiling face versus sad face eyes
closed eyes open all that stuff was
already in there training something on
top of that to then recognize whether
somebody is happy or sad becomes very
very easy to do and so keep that in mind
that that that's the common thread for
today's lecture um so the goal in
representation learning is to pre-train
a neural Net Connection
is make sure I didn't plug poorly the
goal is to pre-t tral network so it can
be fine-tuned to have good performance
on a downstream task with limited
Downstream data generative models they
can achieve this but today we're going
to look at Alternatives which do not
involve a generative model
okay we're chatting before a lecture
here and uh somebody brought up over 300
slides today yeah it's a it's an amazing
set of slides lots of slides um one of
the crazy things about svise Lear and
thanks Philip for uh contributing your
your fair share um amazing about sales
learning is that there's just so many
different ideas um the other thing
that's a little funny about is that the
ideas tend to be very pragmatic and
conceptual there don't tend to be a
whole lot of mathematical derivations
involved with the VA there's lot of
derivation to get what we needed to get
with a again once you start thinking
about it there's a lot of math too with
these sales rised methods it's almost
like a massive bag of tricks combined
with good deep learning expertise and
all of a sudden you can get amazing
results and sometimes better than other
times um as you'll see the master of all
tricks the you know camming her um has
written that some of the most important
papers we'll cover today he just gets
things working other people didn't know
could work which is very interesting and
I think it's a pretty unique thing about
self-supervised learning um we'll see in
the beginning of lecture some things
that people tried it didn't work and
then 5 years later King redid it and it
worked and it's state-ofthe-art so
interesting things ahead
here a version of un learning where data
provides the supervision um in general
we withhold some part of the data and
the task in real network is Task with is
to predict the data we withheld so some
data pull some out neet fill it back in
um that's that's the big picture for all
of today pretty much um but choosing the
right kind of task the right kind of
data or angle of data to slice out is
really what makes all the
difference I want to give a little extra
motivation this is from a keynote Yan
laon gave at nurbs I believe in December
2015 or December 2016 so um quite a few
years ago at the time all the excitement
was reinforcement learning I'm still a
big fan of reinforcement learning but
back then everybody's excited about
reinforcement learning cuz deep Minds
breakthroughs with Alpha go um the T
games a Bri we had the robotic learning
breakthroughs and so everybody's excited
about deep uh deep reinforcement
learning and Y want to give people a
reality check it's not all about
reinforcement learning he said you know
you need data most of your data is going
to be unsupervised or self-supervised
that's the foundation of the cake that's
the big data then you might label a
little bit that is now known as the
supervised fine tuning stage of chat he
essentially predicted the chat GPD
sequence of of training um and then the
final step is essentially the RH CH the
RL which is a cherry on the cake where
we have the smallest amount of data um
it's important to make things work the
way you want them to work but it's
really the tiny thing that happens all
the way at the end so I think pretty
interesting that essentially chat gbt
the way it was trained completely
predicted six seven years before that by
uh Yan Lon with his
cake well the foundation of the cake is
what we're focused on today and there's
a lot to cover um uh let's just dive in
I guess
so even before deep learning was truly
successful actually there was already
work on selfs supervised learning yes
question question like you
[Music]
mention mod aut
and what the difference between
unised what's the difference between
survis and self survis learning I would
say unvis learning is any kind of
learning where you don't do any explicit
effort for data annotation you might
still write a download script to
download a bunch of data but you're not
sitting there adjusting labels or
anything like that that's unsupervised
learning now within unsupervised
learning I would argue there is two
categories one category is generative
models and the other category is self
supervised learning generative models
you can use the model that you train to
regenerate data like your training data
sell supervised learning typically
that's not the intent or possible and so
it's a different category of models that
we'll cover today but that's how I would
uh essentially sketch out the
landscape turn how people were doing
salv learning even before deep learning
worked so deep learning only started
working in 2012 with Alex net
breakthrough um even before that people
were doing Sal vir learning in fact
people did not have to make deep
learning work and for the longest time
people thought that maybe the only way
to get it to work is by doing self
learning um and then fine-tuning
afterwards that's what people were
trying at the time and it was in some
sense to many people are surprised when
alexnet came out that it was fully
supervised there was no pre-training
nothing just fully supervised got the
job done uh big surprise at the time to
most people at least I'm sure not to
Jeff but to most people so in the
noising auto encoder you have a image in
this case you add noise to it that's
number two but with a bunch of noise you
encode that image you then decode it and
hopefully you get back out the original
image might remind you of diffusion
models put noise on it try to den noise
it in fact when you look at the picture
this way it's essentially um the same
thing um but um bear with me as we go
through this so the way this was done
back in 2010 Because deep learning was
actually very hard to do gradients
wouldn't propagate through the Network
back then um the tricks didn't exist to
get the grains to propagate so things
are trained one layer at a time so you
have your image you encode with one
layer you decode with one layer and you
hope you recover a denoised version
after you do that for a while you've
train your first layer of your encoder
and your last layer of your decoder and
then you start doing this again and
again so what kind of noise could be
gaussian noise could be masking noise
could be salt and pepper noise which
means saturated to bottom or top level
of activation that's possible so people
try all these kinds of things might
remind you of many things happening
today but this is back in
2010 the way to think of this is that as
you put noise on your data you're
essentially pushing your data off the
manifold and what the denoising auto
encoder is learning is to get you back
onto the
manifold um this is what it would look
like essentially you have some kind of
loss where you try to have your
reconstruction be as close as possible
to your original um let's not get into
details details have all changed
dramatically since then um then you uh
repeatedly stack that and can get a deep
Network that's trained itally layer by
layer to then have a representation that
might you know take multiple layers to
to compute then at the end you add on a
supervised cost uh or typically called
loss these days and you train for what
you care about let's say classification
or segmentation or something
else of course might remind you of
diffusion models which effectively are
doing the same thing um in you know
conception at least the same thing the
details have changed but you put noise
on your data and you learn to denoise it
um diffusion models are generative
models in that we can start from a
completely noisy image and turn it into
uh image that looks like a real image um
but same thing with diffusion models you
could pre-train and then you could later
f tune or even zero shot annotate for
segmentation um so think of diffusion
models maybe as the modern incarnation
of these Den noising Auto
encoders how about instead of putting
noise on it you mask things out this
work started here in Berkeley
2016 um predict the missing pieces the
idea being if a neural network and at
this time people have figured out how to
train deeper networks so you could in
one GO train a deep Network to solve a
more complicated task let's train it to
fill in the
blank now it's not a deterministic task
but you have supervision and your
training Network to try to match what's
in your supervision while also having
some generalization
capabilities so the network takes in the
image with MK out region there's an
encoder then there's a decoder that
fills back in uh the blank and you have
a loss that compares to
two um there's different choices you can
make in terms of what to blank out a big
region in the middle smaller regions
spread out or maybe you kind of run
maybe some kind of segment or something
else that you have and just segment out
a whole segment and see if it can learn
to fill uh dab back
in one of the things uh that they notice
is that it's important to use both a
reconstruction loss and an adversarial
loss when you just use reconstruction
laws as you'll see on well it's not
there yet as you'll see on one of the
next slides um you fill in with
something very smooth out doesn't look
very real it doesn't learn enough if you
include an adversarial loss like in Gans
you get a much more interesting uh
fill-in-the blank Behavior and the
notation here is essentially just saying
that the loss is only defined on the
regions of the image where you had a
blank there's no loss on other parts of
the image you don't worry about what the
network is doing there now you could
debate that you could say maybe
adversarial law should be on the you
know in some sense acting on the entire
image because if you fill in a blank and
it looks realistic but it doesn't match
well with what's outside the blank then
what are you doing you didn't really get
it right um but in their work they chose
to have adversarial loss focused on just
a blank and the Reconstruction law
hopefully helps ensure that it's filled
in in a compatible way rather than just
in a realistic
way so here's what their architecture
looked like the kind of networks that
were used um back then you could
probably I mean King her revisit this
we'll talk about that with more modern
architectures um but this is what was
kind of the first incarnation of
this if you just use the L2 loss you get
this fuzzy fill in in the second image
if you just use adversarial loss you get
a very realistic fill in for the blank
but it it doesn't really pay attention
to anything else but it looks realistic
for the blank uh if you use the joint
loss for training and then fill back in
you get something much closer to what
you
want um then there was a comparison here
so you pre-train fill in the blank I
believe that did is on um image net
which was a larger data set and then
they look at classification on image net
which is the the large data set at the
time and then they look at detection and
segmentation on a different data set
called Pascal which is a much smaller
data set and so what you see here is the
effect of imag net pre-training helping
detection and segmentation on Pascal um
you can see that um the hours so the
fill in the blank is pretty competitive
with the other um sales revised methods
not the old way at the top but quite
competitive same for detection and same
for segmentation where it's actually
best um supervised pre-training on image
net was still better and in fact that's
a trend you'll see that only once people
started training on very large data sets
much larger than the image net uh data
set you train more uh larger scale you
start getting real benefits from self-
revised
learning okay so the whole point is you
predict one View From Another you go
from raw data to corrupted raw data Den
noising Auto encoder and try to recover
the original um you could do this across
channels so what if you had multiple
channels let's say RGB maybe you can
blank out some channels instead of a
region and try to reconstruct the other
channels there's also an alas group
actually here at Berkeley uh they were
doing a lot of the early work in this
space
um the original image is a color image
it's translated in a space not RGB but
La L is essentially like the Grays scale
image and then AB are the color aspects
of the image if you combine them
together you get back the original image
just a different space compared to
RGB and so they said what if we set it
up we convert all our images to lab
space give the network has input the L
Channel and ask you to predict the A and
B
Channel that's a well-defined prediction
prom and all color images on the
internet you can just download and train
on them so it's a very nice um way to do
things of course if your final
classification task cares about color
you might be a little bit out of luck
because you don't get as much
information about color the way you
learn in your sised learning but you
actually implicitly learn a lot about
color because you learn to fill it in um
and you learn a lot about the structure
of what's in the image to do that well
and so here's what it can do um fill
fill things back in um then one thing
they looked at is okay what loss should
we use back then it wasn't yet so uh
common to avoid the L2 loss so the L2
laws on reconstruction um give that
tends to give those average results you
can't model a multimodal distribution so
if your training examples are such that
really there's a multimodal prediction
that might be needed to cover the
distribution of outcomes L2 is a bad fit
and with coloring actually it's often
the case that there's multiple possible
cars the car could be blue or green or
maybe uh red and so forth and that's all
not always so easy to see from the
grayscale image what color a car or a
bird really is so you get something in
between uh brownish Birds come out all
the time but if you do pixel-wise
classification meaning as you color back
in it's a lodged with 256 values for
each Chanel Channel then you can model
multimodal distributions meaning that
then when you sample you can also get uh
one of the peaks of that multimodal
distribution sampled rather than being
somewhere averaging between uh
possibilities so they didn't they did
this um you know that was one of main
observations on the paper using the you
know the cross entropy discrete loss
effectively rather than the L2 loss
makes a pretty big difference um and
then they augmented this with another
version of this where they said oh what
if we instead of splitting into L and ab
and L is the input and ab is the output
What If instead we split into L and ab
then we have two networks process it and
they each have to recover the thing that
they don't have and then we add them
together and the final loss is on how
well it reconstructs the um original
image in some sense and that's called
split brain Auto encoder um and here's
what you get uh in you know a pass
through this kind of network F1 and F2
are the train networks here um to
recover the opposite channels and then
combined you get the predicted image
back obviously you got to be a little
bit careful because the simplest
solution of all you do is doing addition
at the end is to just pass everything
through not try to predict the opposite
there must be an additional loss there
to prevent that uh from
happening you can use with other things
here they did it with depth channels and
RGB so you have a rgbd camera collect
data from that and then try to do cross
model
prediction now one of the things that I
thought was pretty intriguing then um a
different groups this group showed that
if you do color prediction even though
it might be hard maybe in video you can
frame the problem slightly differently
you can say hey instead of predicting
color from nothing I'm going to give
myself access to the very first frame of
the video
and then I get gray scale and I'm
supposed to predict the color in all the
future
frames now you have a much better posed
problem we know that multimodal
distributions are much harder to to
train for than unimodal you get much
closer to unimodal distribution in this
case is really what you're doing is you
have to look up in the first frame for
everything you see in a later frame what
it corresponds to and so it's a way to
phrase a correspondence learning problem
effectively
and it actually works really really well
look at this like car um coming through
so obviously the car is not all green
but the way this is highlight same for
the burst they don't have that color to
people but it's to highlight a
segmentation you segment in the first
frame what you want to track and then it
shows how it tracks it throughout uh the
video so you get some really good um
learning to to track uh
objects now the paper that probably had
the most influence in the vision space
at least in self surv learning is the ma
paper mass auto
encoders um interestingly along the same
line of work but just some details maybe
we gotten a bit more right it was more
the right time maybe to try it
um in the Mast Auto encoder the input is
an image a bunch of regions are masked
out then an encoder encode
the non-med out regions patches and then
from that you get an embedding then a
decoder um puts blanks for the missing
pieces and then starts decoding uh onto
hopefully back to the original
image you see what I put there big
encoder big decoder small that's a
design Choice um the reason it's chosen
that way is well you want an encoder
that can capture the origins of what's
in images to get interesting semantic
representations so the encoder is
actually what we care about here we
don't care about the decoder we actually
you kind of throw that away afterwards
the encoder is the thing you care about
in this training so let's spend our
compute
there the other thing that's happening
here is that the encoder only has to
process a small fraction of the patches
the kind of hyperparameter setting that
tends to be uh popular is only 25% of
the patches remain 75% of the patches
are masked out
okay so the encoder only has process a
quarter of uh the amount of data that
comes in compared to the
decoder um another thing that's
interesting here is that if you want to
process a patched up image effectively
um traditionally images are done with
convet it's pretty complicated if
convenants like somehow deal with these
patched up images where some pieces are
missing and so forth let alone like
really throwing out 75% not even doing
any calculation for those locations um
so this also coincided with Transformers
becoming much more popular in computer
vision the architecture uses a vision
Transformer and so a Transformer has a
very easy time um essentially just you
know however many patches come through
it just do it has no problem dealing
with that um every patch has a position
encoding so the Transformer knows where
it came from um but it's okay if some
are missing it just you know won't have
any queries going out to those missing
patches so just saved
computation um another thing that's
worth noting is um in this case um the
patches are just with a linear
projection fed into the Transformer
architecture that's pretty simple um and
I think it's a very natural choice
because you're trying to do
representation learning if anything you
put there before you're essentially
forcing some other representation
learning or you have a pre-t trend thing
you put in there there um so makes it
maximally flexible for the encoder to
learn the representation rather than you
forcing anything onto
it so it's pretty interesting what it
looks like though right when 75% is
masked out look at the top left for
example that's a clock but for a human
it's pretty hard to see that that's a
clock um but the me after enough
training can recover uh the blanked out
patches and show that's indeed a clock
same for all of those um and by the way
the 75% masking was a very high masking
ratio I don't think anybody expected
that to be the right amount of masking
until it was shown to be the thing to do
um look at the earlier paper we covered
just block out some region in the middle
or some region little somewhere else it
was nowhere near
75% and the counterpart in language bir
which had been around for a while mased
out about 25 30% so the natural thing to
try and vision would be to also do 25
30% maybe people tried it got not that
great results never got published um but
in this paper they decided 75% might be
what's needed and indeed um it does very
well when you mask out enough um the the
intuition people have for this is that
if you don't mask out enough the task
might be too simple and so you you can
just copy things over from patches that
are not masked into the masked patches
and you're not really learning a
representation that's truly
semantic um
these is this is some validation images
you see um so again the reconstructions
are in the middle it's uh it's quite
good
um here's a study of the masking ratio
um if later you do fine tuning or later
you do linear probing um in both cases
it seems like masking ratio around you
know 75% is quite good though for fine
tuning I guess you have more flexibility
um because I guess you get to train more
l later whereas with linear probing you
need to learn your entire representation
during the cell supervised learning so
you need to get the cell supervised
learning to to be done better is a
question somewhere
yes yeah how come something this simple
could be so much better than what was
there before
um sometimes people just Overlook the
right things and sometimes the right
time to do something and it's a
combination of both
so this came right after the vision
Transformer came out which was the first
paper showing that Transformer
architectures if you have large enough
training data they might need a bit more
training but you have large enough
training set they can do as well as
componets okay um now there's two
aspects of that one Transformers are
very flexible so it might help to use a
Transformer architecture here but until
then it was not necessarily expected in
Vision that would work seemed like were
such a great prior locality and so forth
and so try is with confidence in the
past hadn't worked out all that well the
other thing is when you try with a
confident it's actually very hard to
make this work because what does it mean
to mask something out you're putting
blanks there but your convolutions still
run over it and so you're still
processing those regions you're just
processing zeros there and so it's kind
of a you kind of get an out of
distribution Behavior Uh whereas with a
Transformer you don't get the out of
distribution Behavior you just have as
many others that you can do a query to
and that's it and it gets normalized
your inputs and everything just works
out doesn't matter how big or small your
images or how many patches whereas with
confident where you mask how you mask
all that stuff will influence later in
the fine tuning when you're not masking
what happens now so there's like a
mismatch a fundamental mismatch to fine
tuning and I think people also just
never thought of this big a masking
ratio being the thing to do um it's it
was very surprising in that that's how
much you have to mask and sometimes
that's part of it the devil's in the
details it's possible somebody tried a
vision Transformer tried all the same
things but didn't mask as much and the
masking gives the right inductive bias
to learn semantics but also allows you
to scale up the training because you
mask out
75% you can effectively train something
four four times bigger because you only
to do one quarter of the work for each
data point that you get in and so you
can train a bigger encoder train them
more data four times more than somebody
who doesn't mask much so yeah I mean
it's it's interesting how these things
play
out I would say at the time to give a
bit more context and Philip will talk
about that line of work um the the bets
people were making or the the most like
commonly used approaches to self
supervised learning in computer vision
were not based on masking they were
based on something called contrastive
learning very different line of work um
and that there was a lot of progress in
that line of work has many interesting
ideas that still are quite relevant but
to some reason people had stopped trying
to straight up mask things out and fill
it black in um interestingly caming also
did one of the main papers on the
contrastive learning front so he covered
both with his work um but I think
actually sometimes that's how it is you
know you work on something you're at the
frontier and you start realizing maybe
there's still something missing and
while everybody else is still excited
about this line of work and thinks
that's where they should go you've
already thought that actually there
should there's the next thing that you
should be moving to and that's ideal if
that's that's what you can
do so comparison with prior State
of-the-art consistently beating it will
cover some of these Works um none of
these have ex have this kind of format
that of fill in the blank um so it's
pretty actually beit does but was like a
in some sense like an attempt that Mee
that got a few details wrong and hence
didn't work as well but it was it
happened before and it was a step in in
the right direction in some
sense so there are many ma cousins and
derivatives most of these are
derivatives and that's also acknowledged
in the name they all have the Mae or AE
at the end of uh their name and giving
credit to the ma paper beit actually
happened before Mee but I didn't cover
it before because me is the most
important one today um but now I'll also
tell you what bit did so this was saying
why don't we just do bird pre-training
of image Transformers so also
Transformers also fill in the blank um
what did they do different um so they um
pre-trained a
tokenizer and then effectively the
masking in um in the tokenization space
which means that
um
you don't learn part of it in this
process part of it has been pre-trained
with a discrete vae which might be
something you want or don't want but you
kind of don't have access to that that's
pre-trained the other thing that
happened in their setup is that they um
didn't mask out as much um and so that's
another setting they did differently and
they did not
um they did not remove the Mast out
patches they also processed the masked
out patches so those are some
differences between the two papers and
again to your question you know where
did it come from how it work now not
it's it's these details I mean bit is
essentially as close as it gets to me
without getting there at least in the
history of how things were
developed um video me builds directly on
me and says okay well why not do the
same thing for
video um couple of things to think about
they call they call out this notion of
two tube masking um what is tube masking
it means that usually when you have a
video if in a certain region of the
frame there is something now it might
also be there in the next frame so you
should mask out where in a specific
region you mask out everything or maybe
nothing CU if you sometimes mask out
this location then that location you can
just copy from the previous frame to the
next frame to fill in that region and
the task becomes too easy so that's what
they call tube masking make sure you
can't do simple copy
from frame one to frame two and so
forth otherwise essentially Mae um High
masking ratio even higher than me 90 to
95% why because video is even more
redundant than images so you need to
mask out even more to prevent things the
task from becoming too simple very
impressive results even on very small uh
data sets this is the pre-training
actually even when they pre-t turn on
relatively small data at 3,000 videos to
get good representation learning one
their observations was that data quality
is more important than data quantity for
this pre-training and the main shift
between pre-training and Target data
sets is an important factor so video me
with a vanilla vit Vision Transformer
backbone can achieve 87.4% on kinetics
400 um these numbers in the abstract
maybe don't make that much sense to you
but essentially these are good
performances on these data sets and if
you're looking into video generation or
things related to video These are data
you might want to look at Kinetics 400
something something V2 UCF of 101 and
hmdb 51 uh they're good ones to look up
if you're working in this space or plan
to work here yes what do is meant by
data quality here so um I think what
what they meant is that um they want um
higher quality videos I don't know what
else they tried I don't recall what kind
of other data sets they might have tried
where the the quality wasn't as good
that's a good question we'd have to go
look back back at the
paper so here are their results for
different sizes of vision Transformers
and turns out that on these you know
benchmarks they're considering here they
tend to do very very well and they have
to use no external data um whereas many
of the other previous learning
representations from video and then find
tun on something else had add
pre-training uh on other data sets yes
question
soing stuff like the diffusion models
and the stuff you were showing from 2010
earlier it's effectively like you noise
all the data and then you're trying to
extrapolate the original image from
something that looks nothing like the
image and then here it's almost like
interpolation when you mask things out
you just want to fill in the blanks but
it seems like extrapolation is a better
way to learn cuz they're almost masking
everything out to learn so it's like is
it better to remove as much of the
initial information as possible because
right now like diffusion models work the
best from what I understand and that
basically removes everything through
that iterative noising process so is
that why this extreme masking is
better so the question is essentially
how extreme should the masking be and
how much noise to add and and what are
the trade-offs um in these papers the
finding is that you need to mask out a
lot um I think you essentially mask
out as much as you can while the thing
still can come up with some kind of
solution to your problem I think the
challenge if you mask out too much is
that the solution could become
multimodal and multimodal distribution
modeling is harder and so you probably
want to mask out as much as possible
while somehow having a unimodal
distribution over what the fill in
should be now what does that exactly
mean in terms of amount of masking I
think you just do it by you know doing a
hyperparameter search if you compare to
diffusion models they can come all the
way back from Full noise onto real image
but if you go to full noise they don't
come back to the original image like we
saw in the examples when in the original
diffusion paper you could go a th
diffusion steps and you wouldn't recover
the original image you could go up to
500 and you could still recover the
original image and so now to us that
noise after 500 step image is pretty
hard to still discern what's going on
but I guess to a computer it's still
more clear uh CU not as distracted by
all the little noise pickles it's my
hunch um but I would also I mean the
other question you had is are the
diffusion models better than these
diffusion models are the best for
Generation right now I don't think
they're necessarily always the best for
representation learning I think a lot of
representation learning today um is
still done with mass auto encoders for
for
vision thank you
experiments on kinetics 400 um so
typically in this video they says
essentially you need to recognize an
activity so kinetics 400 means that
there's 400 different activities and
when you are doing the fine-tuning or
the linear probing you're asked to learn
to predict what activity was happening
in this particular
video so V is very good um here's
another idea again I think a lot of
today's uh papers that we cover the
ideas are very clever but then the math
doesn't have to be that deep that's why
we can cover so many papers um but often
in deep learning that's the winning
strategy the more complex your math
becomes it's almost like almost
guarantee that your experiment won't
scale as well if it doesn't scale as
well then your results won't be as good
so it's good to keep things relatively
simple but you want to leverage some
kind of intuition right think back to
the um to the coloring right we got the
first frame and then gray scale for the
future frames and you color back in by
being able to refer to the first frame
and we got an automatic segmentor out of
it effectively a Tracker in the C Mae
architecture that's essentially
revisiting that exact same idea but with
the tools from 5 years later use a
vision Transformer use the Mae idea and
the results get better um so here you
have a video you will get the initial
frame you'll pfy and code keep
everything you take a future frame you
mask almost everything out and the task
is to fill it back
in now in the video ma we didn't want to
do that we said we could just copy
things over it's too easy we're not
going to learn the right representations
but that depends on what you're trying
to do in video M we're trying to learn
semantic representations might this be a
dog jumping or a dog maybe lying on the
couch that's different semantics but
here the goal is to learn to track to
segment and so it's a very different
goal of what's being trained for and
when you want to learn to track you want
to learn to make correspondences with
the previous image and understand where
things ended up in the next image and so
the way to think of this and that's how
the authors explain I really like the
explanation is the few patches you get
to see are essentially telling you how
things moved give you a global sense of
how things moved and now your NE network
from that needs to be able to fill in
where everything else is going to move
to make it consistent and being able to
do that makes it able to do good
tracking 95% masking in that second
frame um I'll perform stateof the-art
self supervised methods on video object
segmentation keyo propagation and
semantic part propagation so these are
all segmentation propagation propagation
tasks different from the video me which
is about
classification so here's what this looks
like but actually there's some really
cool um videos that I want to show
this in
action so here is what comes out of it
in terms of the ability to to track so
you essentially annotate in the first
frame what you want to track and then or
who you want to track and then from
there it just automatically tracks that
throughout the
video here's another one where um you're
supposed to track
essentially the the skeleton that
explains the I guess the pose of the
person and again it's able to you know
learn to do
that state-of your art performance um
thanks to this kind of
pre-training and
then should be one
more this one here is Parts tracking so
is a
person um you actually split up and
let's say hair face t-shirt and so forth
and it can track the components or the
parts of that person throughout yes
question so when you say that you
annotate the first image like do you
like literally paint parts of it
different colors I don't know what they
did here that's a good question how did
they annotate the first image I could
see this happen in two ways one is if
you care about something specific
yourself probably what you do is you run
a standard segmenter on your image and
then you click on the regions that you
say these are the regions that
constitute the object I care about maybe
it already has that as a separate object
Maybe not maybe you need to merge some
or split something um or you can in
principle just segment the initial scene
automatically and then just let it track
all segments over time that's not what
they did here maybe because that's hard
to see what's going on because there
might be a lot of little segments doing
things that are hard to make sense of
and so the examples here they focused on
like the main subjects in in the video
and yeah I don't know if they manually
chose the segments or whether they had
some kind of other system say like grab
the person and then track um either way
is reasonable and then as far as like
producing all these future frames do
they essentially like take the first
frame and then take the next frame which
is not segmented and then mask it out
predict it with
the that's a good question I should look
up the details again uh to answer that
question but I think there are two
options here or you you remember yeah
yeah they they essentially take they
encode the first frame extract out those
features and then they condition on that
frame and then use the encoder to
extract out corresponding features and
they try to match the features with the
original frame so they just for each
frame frame by frame they're just doing
a pair wise matching and then they
project that back
into thank you
philli yes question you have say you
have a scenario where instead of a video
you have several images Tak the same
instance to back would you need would it
be able to work or because the the
number of images cannot come close to
this in terms of aailable frame you can
do the
same you mean in terms of training yes
so yeah I mean to train this you do the
Assumption here to train this is that
you have video that is Meaningful in a
consecutive sense if you had Cuts in the
middle of your video you want to
essentially curate your data set that
when there's a cut and you go to a
different scene that that becomes a
separate part of your your you know a
new item in your training set you don't
want transitions across those because
you're not going to be able to color
things in or in this case I guess fill
in the blank uh across those cuts all
that easily um but it all depends maybe
for some Cuts you can still do it um but
if it's a cut to a completely different
scene then you probably stand no chance
so in some sense yes I mean it's worth
worth I guess highlighting that even
though we call it self-supervised and
unsupervised learning there is a certain
amount of data curation still
happening now some of it can be scripted
you might say hey if my frame next frame
is this much different from the previous
frame I assumed there was a cut and I'm
going to split it up um so there are
ways to maybe script it but there is
some kind of work involved making sure
that your you know your training data is
well behaved with respect to the
assumption you make here for the
training this is kind of just
highlighting the state-of-the-art
performance attained on these tracking
tasks so because this is
um video object segmentation human post
propagation and semantic part
propagation and this work is stateof the
art on across all of
them so how you can do the same thing in
a different modality audio um you encode
your audio into a spectrogram which
means essentially you take Windows in
time and take the frea transform over
that window and look at the data in in
the frequency domain uh for that
interval um fitting only the non-mas
tokens through encoder layer so just
like Mae uh decoder same as me you
reorder to make sure things are in the
right spot fill in the blanks um local
window attention in the decoder this is
a little different they had a decoder
that's a bit more attuned to audio data
where apparently there is a lot more
locality uh that matters and so little
extra work on the decoder there um
finding the encoder with a lower masking
ratio on target data sets um that that
might be to get more in distribution uh
for when you do your your Downstream
tasks and then um apparently sets new
state ofr performance on six audio and
speech classification tasks out
performing other recent models that use
external supervised pre-training so
after me paper came out is just like
this sequence of works that came out
that establish new stateof the Arts in
selfis pre-training or even any kind of
pre-training this is the architecture
you turn your audio signal into the
spectrogram you remove most patches uh
do an encoder decoder and um that's
Essen ma it looks like me pretty much
because pictogram looks like like an
image um these are some of the numbers
they achieved I'm not an expert in a
hard for me to give a lot of detailed
common on these numbers but um I think
the important takeaway here is that it's
achieving
state-of-the-art and the beauty of ma is
of course that it's one of the simplest
ideas it's just fill in the blank uh so
it's nice to see the simplest thing do
so
well multi so what it did here is it
said you know why why just you know one
modality why not multiple modalities and
you can have different kind of mask out
ratios for different modalities or
different combinations of ratios and
then you can learn to fill in other
modalities um maybe have RGB as always
then you have depth maybe have semantics
they use semantic segmentation as one of
their input channels which doesn't
really feel like all that
self-supervised but their take was
essentially there's a lot of pretty
decent segmentation algorithms um run
those
combined with this
um it's not being trained to do
segmentation it's trained to do
representation learning and so having
also the segmentation as part of the
training effectively makes it work
harder um to also figure out some of
those things and um it helps in their
experiments and then at test time you
can in principle then use it as a
segmentor of course a segmentor will
only be as good as as your pre-labeled
segmentation there data but your
representation learning uh might be uh
very good and then you can find tune on
more segmentation data if you
want um encoder only process the
non-mass tokens that's the common theme
uh shallow decoders uh pseudo labels for
the non-rgb
modalities um evaluations on image net
1K um I don't really know the other data
sets as well
um semantic segmentation data sets and
apparently doing quite
well more experiments here so these are
cross model predictions RGB input into
depth prediction into semantic
prediction you go from depth to the
other two or semantic to the other two
um so some sense it's a bit of a
generative model in this case because it
can reconstruct other modalities from
the original
input this is a work we did at at
Berkeley um at the time there wasn't
really anything yet this is now um a
year and a half ago anything yet that
was um particularly good at multimodal
learning between text and images um
there was the clip-like learning which
was the essentially contrastive learning
Philip will cover um but there wasn't
something Mae style that might actually
be be
better um so the dominant multimodal
presentation learning Paradigm at the
time was contrastive
learning downside of cross model
contrastive is that it only works with
pair data all your data has to be paired
otherwise it doesn't really contribute
to the to the training um this case um
we found out multimodal pre-training of
m3a um on this close captioning data set
achieves uh significantly higher
performance on the image at 1K linear
classification Benchmark compared to
pre-training on images only so there's
something about the multi that's helping
extract a better representation of
images not too unexpected because
obviously having that semantic
information should tell you something
about the images that is not just there
if you do just image training but it's
nice to see it confirmed um performance
best when apply a high mask ratio even
on language which was a bit surprising
at the time at the time on language
everybody used like 30% birdlike masking
in this case 75% seem to be a better
choice Maybe because there is a
complimentary information in the images
uh in fact sometimes even lower than 30%
on on the uh bird models encoder image
patches and language tokens Vision
Transformer decoder also very
lightweight following all the Mae uh I
guess learned
lessons uh you feed in image pafi it
only feed in the patches that are not
masked out you feed in the text you also
blank things out there your encoder does
then a lot of the work and a decoder
supposed to reconstruct uh the pair or
sometimes just the image just a text if
that's all you
have um comparison just a second
comparison with Mee um on um fine tuning
accuracy it's strictly better than just
Mee this a pure Vision task um linear
accuracy it's a lot better showing that
the underlying representation learned is
a lot better than the underlying Mee
representation learned but if the
network is large I guess if you fine tun
and everything you can still get pretty
close with
Mee last one in this um category that I
want to highlight is the multiv view
Mast World models the idea here is to do
the same
thing but now with multiple cameras
looking at the same
scene so imagine a camera camera looking
from different viewpoints filling in the
blank for other viewpoints requires a
pretty deep semantic and geometric
understanding of the scene Philip will
talk more about that one as he's
covering a bunch of works that
essentially think of this in the context
of vision based robotic
control let's see there was a question
here up front yes um two sides we're
looking at the Ping um for the text here
MH the the pches you also um for the
text that you mask out are you ensuring
that do you have to ensure they're the
same as the ones from the
images so in this case these are paired
so it's a paired image and text so what
the image partes that that I do not mask
out do I ensure that my text at least
describes that
part um there's no mechanism to ensure
that you can fully reconstruct I guess
there's just a hyper parameter how much
you patch out and so yeah pretty high
masking ratio allows you to still
recover things pretty well so that's
that's just where the hyper parameter
landed yes randoming in the because that
would also if just off and they're not
really that
informative it's random the mask on the
text is random
yep
okay um then let's switch gears to a
whole different category so Mee style
works is one thing fill in the blank or
fill in other channels uh it's still I
mean it is one of the most popular
purchase today it's not that old um and
it continues to be one of the most
popular purchas
today there are other Tas that people
came up with um I want to highlight them
even though they're maybe not as popular
today it's interesting to
see that they actually gave pretty good
good results um relative patch
prediction jigsaw puzzles rotation I'll
explain them shortly um but maybe the
big picture to think about here is that
at the time before Mae the sense was
that reconstructing the image as a way
of doing representation learning for
vision it's not working out so we need
to think of other ways to do
representation learning and these are
some of the things people came up
with so context uh
prediction um here you're supposed to
predict the relative position of the
second patch respect to the first so
look at this on the left you see a nose
and eyes of a cat on the right you see
what's probably ear of a cat and
probably like the ear that goes in the
top right of the image if the nose and
eyes are in the middle let's say that's
because we understand things about cats
right if youve never seen a cat or any
any animals you would probably not be
able to to predict iict that and so
essentially what we're trying to do is
force the vision model to understand the
visual World in a way that it can
reposition things correctly um part of
the beauty here is that all you need is
a classifier right you just need to
classify patches onto um let's say one
of nine locations and so as part of the
side Guist at the time was that it was
hard computationally hard to reconstruct
an entire image maybe it's just not even
necessary what's a cheaper output I can
generate a classification onto 9way
classification that's much cheaper let
me train that and learn in a self-
survis way against that kind of loss if
you look at it these are not perfectly
positioned right they're not a perfect
like equally spaced set of locations the
reason that's the cas and they're also
not actually neighboring and so these
things matter if you make them actually
neighboring you can just look at the
texture very locally to see where it
matches up and then that's where they
are relative to each other you don't
want that to be the solution you want a
semantic understanding to be the
solution to the problem and same thing
you might say oh you know maybe if
you're always in the top right corner
maybe there's some pattern about being
top right corner that's not so much
semantic about the the thing here and so
is there an artifact at the edge of the
image or something so you don't want
necessarily be all the way at the edge
because that might give away um where
you are in the
image so um CNN processes this that's
what was the state-of art at the time um
outputs I guess eight possible locations
because the center is is given and
you're supposed to classify the others
onto um the where they might be uh we
were right it was the top right of the
image um talk about includeed Gap Jitter
the patch locations and in fact the
thing on the right is illustrating
Jitter the colors so locally the color
pattern might have a certain due to
lighting and so forth might have a
certain pattern to it you don't want to
thing to say oh I'm going to pay
attention to the detailed color pattern
to know that these are actually
neighboring right there you want again
the confident in this case to understand
the semantics of what's in the image um
so Random perturbations added to make
sure the solution is not too easy based
on local
texture um from there you could go to
solving jigsaw puzzles um you have nine
pieces um essentially you know you can
permute these in nine factorial ways
which is not a tiny number but it's not
a super large number it's I don't know
it's maybe roughly like th000 10,000
outputs or something on your classifier
for all the nine factorial um possible
uh configurations and so um that's the
output here and again make sure they're
not actually neighboring and do the
right jittering um and so actually
they're going to 64 not sure how get to
just 64 um we have to look up how that's
oh no it's just deciding it's in it's
permutation 64 um but all possible
permutations are allowed it shows that
permutation 64 is the one it decided was
the correct output for this
one then actually somebody came out with
this thing all you have to do is predict
now the rotation of the
image image is taken downloaded oh
question all did after you finish this
but I'm curious how well these
techniques transfer to less object
centri data sets so in a lot of the
examples the object is like very much
the clear focus of the image but in more
cluttered images first do the
representations transfer and is it
possible to learn similarly good
representations under less qu that's
that's a good good question to what
extent is the the success of n as a
purchase tied to the type of data which
is you know photography data focused on
specific items or subjects whereas a
robot going around the world doesn't
have the same kind of visual data coming
in it's a very good question
um it's definitely the case that um a
lot of these things don't generalize
that well to data that doesn't follow
the photography pattern um now that's
that's when they're trained this way and
then tested on other data that doesn't
really evaluate the methods so I don't
know if there are such I mean somebody
would have to collect the data under the
other distribution that you have then
rerun the method and see if it still is
a good method or not which I don't know
um if anybody has really done that but I
do know alos fos used to have this
beautiful slides where he would use this
like object Centric data which are all
the data sets essentially and then use
the trained classifier on some random
Youtube data and it would just like be
pretty bad at classifying what's what's
in
those
so the idea here again is we want to
force semantic understanding of what's
in the image but we don't want to label
the image and so if we have it predict
which of the four possible rotations was
applied it should understand
semantically what's in the image because
then it understands the the natural way
for this in this case bird to be
positioned now do you think this is
better than a jigsaw puzzle do you think
it's better than coloring and so forth
it's pretty hard to know turns out that
this worked the best of all these tricks
this is the one that worked the best um
which definitely ties into how people
take pictures especially this one
because you know the way you position
the camera determines whether this was
rotated or not right um but and then the
investigate what if you have more
possible rotations it seems like maybe
it could do even better a harder
classification problem turns out that
doesn't really help maybe like these
kind of non 90° rotations are just weird
and and make for a different kind of
setting um so you see here um this is on
you know essentially pre Trend uh I
think this is probably alexnet or a
similar architecture with this rotation
prediction and then you use the con 4 or
con five layer to then uh uh do linear
classification on image net and you um
do the best with this rotation Network
better than any of the others we've seen
here not better than Mae which later but
any of the other uh tricks uh that we
saw um but at the time actually IM that
using the labels uh worked even even
better um this is uh if you use a
different com layer so count one is the
earliest layer doesn't do nearly as well
obviously it does not have as semantic a
representation as layers four and
five then test on Pascal for detection
segmentation
um also achieving stateof the art here
against all of these others that we we
talked about colorization jigsaw split
brain um
colors
um all of these are performed by
rotation that but again all of these
then in turn outperformed by mast Auto
encoders since then also outperformed by
eye clear s not I clear a Sim clear Moco
uh which Philip will cover
later
okay um let's take our break a bit early
today we'll restart at um 25 past the
hour and we'll look at some other uh
pretty interesting cell supervis
learning
methods
um okay so T covered um a large variety
of methods but now we'll go into another
really popular approach that people have
used for uh self-supervised
learning um called contrastive learning
so kind of the first success along this
line of work was this paper presented
this paper representation learning with
contrasted predictive coding this was
done at deepmind back in
2018 and the idea that they had
here um and the kind of setting that
they were approaching here is audio so
that's what's being visualized down here
and what we have over here is some
context of the audio C and some future
chunk of this audio
X and um what we've seen before with the
Reconstruction type objectives is that
we might want to try to predict X from C
but in this contrastive type of approach
we don't actually directly predict
X instead what we'll do is we'll try to
predict
some um representation of of
X and the kind of formulation that they
motivate is we want to try to maximize
the mutual information between the
context see as well as what we're trying
to predict in the future
so what that looks like in practice is
we can try to effectively look at our
context
c um and then try
to match C with this Vector Z our future
Vector Z with a bunch of other potential
candidates for Z and you can imagine
these future candidates Z are either
other audio chunks from various
different audio sequences or um
different uh audio chunks within the
same sequence and the goal is that we
want our context SE to be able to match
closely with the one that matches in the
current sequence and we would call that
a positive example whereas the ones that
come from different sequences or ones
that are far away from where we care
about those would be called negative
examples and uh the way we can compare
that is we use some type of distance
metric and the distance metric that they
use in this paper is um a bilinear DOT
product which is essentially just a
regular dot product but we have this
additional weight
Matrix which gives you a little bit more
expressive um
expressivity um and this loss will be
pretty important um this is called they
call this the info nce or noise
contrastive
estimation and this will come up
throughout uh this the rest of this
section of the
presentation
and um so this is what their
architecture looks like that they came
up with so they have some audio encoder
G where they are encoding this audio and
then they have this uh Gru which is
processing these features to create
these context vectors C and that's
essentially aggregating context across
this
audio from that context C they then do
predictions across various different
time chunks in this case they're
predicting just one step ahead um all
the way to steps
ahead um and yeah this is just the info
nce loss that we just talked about and
then um you can try to directly maximize
this and then what's in the denominator
is they take audio chunks from different
from different um audio waveforms that
they've sampled in the same mini
batch and so what you're effectively
doing um in this case case is if you go
back to here you're
taking um yeah you're taking your
context C and you're trying to classify
it against a bunch of different
potential examples and so it has to
learn features that are predictive of
future parts of the audio and help it
differentiate from um other
parts of like non-relevant
audio so this is kind of a visualization
of what happen happens after you do this
type of pre-training with this info nce
objective um on the left is a
visualization of they take 10 different
audio chunks and then they encode it
with their
encoder um G over here and then they
look at the Tey
visualization um all of the ones of the
same color are colored by the audio the
speaker and so you can see that the
model has been able to learn
representations that can cluster
together
different chunks of that waveform from
the same speaker
effectively so another aspect of this
prediction task is it highly depends on
kind of what you choose as how much
you're trying to predict ahead you can
imagine if you try to predict way too
far ahead in the future um it could be a
very difficult task to actually do and
that's what's being represented here um
x-axis is the amount of future time
steps you're trying to predict into and
the y- axis is the a of how well you're
able to predict so if you're trying to
predict immediately after um you can
essenti it's much easier to learn
because there's very high correlation
with the current audio chunk versus the
next one um but it's much harder to do
it if it's further in the
future um so the this is the kind of
speech task that they actually ended up
testing on uh the left is some phony
classification and um they also do some
speaker classification where you're
trying to classify which speaker it
corresponds to which
audio and you can see that CPC in this
phoneum classification does much better
than these um this mfcc features is I
think some hand design features um it's
it's getting close to supervised and at
least in the speaker classification um
it's also getting very close to doing
pure supervised
learning sorry the way that they learned
the classifier for the CPC features is
they took the Frozen features and they
learned the Ling classifier on top of
those features whereas the supervisors
you train a network end to end for the
task and that's a common way again just
like we were doing in Mee the linear
probank test where we'll just take the
Frozen features and then uh stick a ling
your head onto it and then try to learn
a classifier from those learn
features so the nice part about CPC is
you can actually apply this idea to a
whole different bunch of different
domains and that was kind of also part
of the original motivation for CPC is we
wanted to have or they wanted to have a
self-supervised method that could learn
representations across a bunch of
different modalities and you can imagine
that this context to try to predict some
future feature task is very
general and this is how they uh end up
formulating it for
images so they take a patch from the
image um in this case they do 50%
overlapping unlike what we saw with
M uh they extract features through it by
passing each of these patches through a
reset and then they try to predict
features that are
below um below that patch in the image
so in this case this is our context and
we're trying to predict features that
are two three four rows
below uh so visually that looks
something like this this original image
and we patchy it with 50% overlap we get
patches that look like
this
um and by doing this um we
can at the time and this was back in
2018 so if you remember when Peter was
talking about me we're kind of at 70%
over here uh in terms of 1% image net
accuracy but in terms of Back in the Day
in 2018 um this was stateof
VR and they also um yeah t someone uh
this is looking at top 5%
accuracy over here they're looking at
some image net features um they
uh pass some images through the network
look at those features um and then
compare that to features or compare that
patch
across patches of um different images
and you can see that it learns these
pretty nice correspondences where it's
actually learning semantically
meaningful patch features um and able to
do relevant
retrieval um yeah there they extend this
to NLP as well well as well as
reinforcement learning um in this case
you can see that this looks very similar
to what they were doing in audio except
they addition um so now you can do the
same future prediction task as well as
have your original reinforcement
learning objective um so they
essentially add the CPC as an auxiliary
loss U able to show improvements and and
we'll cover more RL and control-based
methods with
um um self-supervised learning a little
bit
so with the original CPC paper they kind
of introduced the idea and showed that
it seemed quite promising as well as the
fact that you could use this across a
wide variety of domains um now we'll
kind of mainly focus on the image domain
because that's where people have been
pushing largely with the self-supervised
methods as well as um these contrastive
methods uh so CPC V2 is essentially just
trying to scale up CPC and get better
results and what we'll see as we have
saw with Mee is that it turns out like a
a lot of tricks and the right insights
can actually go a long way um and it's
hard to exactly tell there's not really
much Theory motivated behind this Beyond
just having good
engineering so what they did in cpcv 2
it's the same setup as before except
they're using much deeper networks so
before I believe they were using resinet
50 and they scaled up to using resinet
161 so 161 um layers
deep extracting out those
features um and then again again you
have your predictor on top your
predictor in this case is like a pixel
CNN type architecture that way it
prevents you from looking in the future
because of course we're trying to
predict into the
future um so yeah this is our context C
and then we're trying to predict the
features Z oft in uh the rows
below again they're using this bilinear
do product as the distance metric
between the feature C and z
uh with the same info andc
loss for negatives yeah W uh W is just
um an additional Lal parameter so you
could just the regular dot product would
just be the Z and C um but you can have
this additional learnable parameter to
try to learn maybe um a more expressive
distance
metric they this is just a thing that
you can like add or remove and they find
that it helps at least with their
Downstream results
um
so uh importantly here they have uh when
they take their negatives or the things
that they're try to classify against
they have patches across other images as
negatives but they also have patches
within the same image as negatives just
not at the rows that they're predicting
um so I think specifically for this they
just Tred to predict only two rows ahead
um and everything else is considered a
negative so you can imagine that makes
the task actually a little bit more
difficult because now you have to know
exactly what would be like two rows
below um the current
patch and again that's like a common
theme that we'll see that if you have to
make the task just hard enough that the
model has to learn like really good
representations but you can't make it
too hard where it's literally impossible
to learn but and you also can't make it
too easy where the task is too trivial
um so there's like always a balance here
with how these tasks uh these training
self-supervised tasks are
defined um so some additional tricks um
that they do they train for much longer
in this case they're training for 500
Epoch which at the time took about a
week um and you can imagine yeah
compared to some of your homeworks is
way longer um they're augment they're
doing a lot of different augmentations
to their images so they're doing like
spatial and color
augmentations and again this number of
negatives is very
important so these are the different
Downstream tasks that they test so they
do this pre-training that we just
described they do this linear
classification on imag net
um uh you can also investigate uh
efficient classification where you don't
provide all the labels you provide maybe
1% or a smaller amount of percentage of
the full labels to your um your tuning
task you can also try this on transfer
learning task where these models are
pre-trained on imag net but maybe we
want to test it on like Pascal block
which is like a b conation in data
set um
so here are the results on uh image net
L your classifier score and we see that
we've gotten huge improvements from what
we saw before so CPC V1 was sitting
around 48% but with cpcv 2 we've gone
all the way up to
61% um of course you know the model
sizes are much bigger so it's a little
hard to directly compare if we look at a
similar model size we see that brings us
back back down to
63.8 um but still still much better than
what we were seeing with CPC
V1 so here are essentially all of the
model improvements that were let them go
up from CPC V1 all the way to CPC V2 um
I won't go into the details of those but
yeah you can look if you're
interested so what this plot is showing
is it's showing
the red curve over here which is just
reset trained on pixels from scratch
versus this blue where you first
pre-train image net
um and then you give it you fine-tune on
a certain percentage of the labels so in
this case we only have 1% of the labels
this is fully supervised um this is
first unsupervised pre-training followed
by supervised fine tuning with 1% of the
data all the way up to 100%
and kind of what this motivates is that
it's always advantageous to do some sort
of unsupervised pre-training on your
data set even at 100% we still see a
small amount of gain by having the
unsupervised pre-training
step and um at very small percentage of
labels you can see that's very very
helpful and so this suggests that with
unsupervised pre-training um we might
need a lot less fewer labels and can be
much more data efficient and kind of
that's definitely what we're seeing
Trend nowadays is uh with massive
internet data we can get a bunch of
unsupervised data and that's really
helping for these Downstream tasks that
we
about cool so that's uh
CPC and next we'll investigate instance
discrimination so what we were looking
at before is we were trying to
contrast part of part of an image with
another part of that same image um but
what we'll now do instead is we'll try
to look at an image in this case this is
the dog and we'll try
to uh look compare that against other
instances of the same dog
versus uh completely other different
images so here's a dog we've made it
gray scale and here's the same dog we've
kind of flipped it and then zoomed in um
and we want those to have similar
representations whereas we want this dog
to have a very different representation
in this
cup uh and these methods will be Moco
and simp
clear so the first one is Moco momentum
contrast for unsupervised visual
representation learning again this one
is from King uh this was back done in
2019 so King was working on this
unsupervised pre-training back then and
at the time he was working on this
contrastive type
objective uh the work that Peter
presented earlier Mae was done in 2021 a
few years later and so ping would first
spend some time in this contrastive type
objective and then later would work on
the Reconstruction objective which uh
yeah we saw had a lot of success as
well the idea with Moco is
um again we have our image X and we're
going to pass it through an encoder to
get some
query and we want to compare that
against augmented versions of itself as
well as random other
instances the issue here however is uh
if we want to have a bunch of things to
compare to that means we need a huge
batch size and at the time um we didn't
have the types of scalable Computing
infrastructure that we did today and so
it often means that if you want to do
this type of contrasting because we're
contrasting now with full images and no
longer patches um which can get you a
lot more samples to contrasting against
you were getting like really small
samples and so that made this type of
like contrastive idea not really work
and so the Insight here instead is we
can take a bunch a history of a bunch of
keys and then cach them in a Quee and
then contrast against this cue
of um Q of samples and there's a couple
of tricks that are necessary to get this
to actually work as well and so part of
that is now we actually need to have
this add momentum to this encoder so we
can't take our query q pass it through
the encoder take an augmentation and
pass it through the same encoder we
actually have to pass it through um this
polya average version of the
encoder so that's this is uh looking at
moo in a little bit more detail so we
take
our observation our image o and we apply
two different augmentations to it for
example like we saw we can turn it to
grayscale or we can flip it and zoom
in we take our feature extractor F and
then that gets our query q and then the
way we get our key is we pass it through
this
polya average version of our encoder
which is essentially just an exponential
moving average of the weights of the
encoder um and then we apply the normal
info NC
loss and again we are actually keeping a
cue of all these keys so once we extract
out this key we keep a long buffer of
these Keys um and we use that in our
negative examples so yeah I think the
best way to understand this is probably
just look at the code um which is
actually quite simple so we can quickly
walk through that right now but
essentially we have our image X we pass
it through a random augmentation and we
get these two different augmentations
and we pass it through um our Network
here we have fq which is the key Network
and then the query Network K here so
that gives us our two
examples um we then just do a matrix
multiply to get the dot
product and then that gives us our
logits and then we try to do the info
nce which is effectively just cross
entropy we're trying to label that this
image should match this augmented
version of the same image and not match
all the other
images and then the negative examples we
just take from our cu which is of this
size um yeah we just take the cross
entropy loss and then you can see over
here here's where we deal with our Q we
then enq the new keys that we got from
this current batch and then we um DQ if
necessary so like once we filled up our
buffer we want to remove out the old
examples
yeah
yeah that's correct so I think one thing
with uh this type of contrastive
objective
is um you want your feature
representation to be agnostic to like
the representation you're trying to
learn should be agnostic to something
and in this case it's like these
augmentations and so the way you choose
these augmentations matters a lot um and
it also matters especially a lot for
your Downstream task and I think that is
one thing about self-supervised learning
that people don't talk enough about is
that oftentimes I feel like it will
heavily depend um on what you care about
in your Downstream task a lot of time we
just treat it as oh you can do some type
of generic pre-training and that I'll
magically improve on your Downstream
task but it should be that your pre-ex
task has some type of overlap in terms
of what you actually care about for your
Downstream tasing to actually get it to
work well um and and in this case for
these classification types task um where
we care about these more object Centric
type features it turns out that these
type of very basic image based
augmentations seem to work out pretty
well
um they
do pretty aggressive augmentations I
would say I mean yeah so usually we'll
see that people will try a whole bunch
of different pensal augmentations but
then generally it's they do very heavy
cropping um or at least one part of the
image will be very heavily cropped um as
well as yeah this type of color
jittering rotation
flipping
yeah I will talk about that right now
so um we can maybe
view potentially different ways that we
we would um we
could take this approach so what uh you
just asked the question why do we need
momentum well maybe we don't need
momentum
so one potential approach that we could
take is uh we have our single image we
get our key in our query pass it through
the same encoder and then we can just do
our info nce laws here our Rive loss and
then back prop through
both um the issue that they had at the
time is it's really hard to fit a big
batch size um just due to compute
limitations and
so the way that you want this to work
well with this contrastive loss is you
want to have a large bat size so you
have enough negatives to compare against
in order to learn semantically
meaningful features because for example
let's say if we go to limit you only
have one in your batch the task is Tri
trivial because you can always classify
against yourself um and so you really
need a really large batch size for this
to perform well so given that we want to
maybe have some type of trick
to keep a larger batch size maybe it
makes sense to have this memory
bank um and and that's what we could
potentially do over
here uh the issue with having a memory
bank like this as your target is you
might result in some type of like
collapse where where you you have your
encoder over here but then these things
are always
fixed um so what they do with the
momentum encoder is you're trying to
take your image X you pass it through
this momentum encoder which is a very
slowly it's not very it's a slowly
moving average of your encoder weight so
you can kind of treat this as a more
stationary distribution and so you're
giving it something a little bit more
static that the encoder has to match
against um and so that helps stabilize
training and prevent um collapse issues
and so that was kind of kind of like the
motivation for why they came up with
this memory bank plus the necessity to
have the momentum encoder and we'll see
that this is a common theme with a lot
of these types of methods is that
because we're kind of trying to predict
in some latent space there's all these
potential issues of um collapse and
having a more slowly moving Target can
help stabilize things
yeah um so
this is um the one this is the accuracy
on image net that were're shown over
here uh this is and and they compare
against the different uh approaches so
nend to end is what we just went over
here this is a and you can see that
they're only able to scale up to a batch
size of 1024 before like compute wise at
the time they weren't able to scale
further beyond
that um if you just use the memory bank
you can see that the performance is
actually a bit lower down here
um and if you use Moco which was the the
very one on the right you can see that
it actually just matches the performance
of the end to end to end approach but it
allows you to much easily scale to huge
batch sizes they were able to scale up
to um
65,000 um and yeah able to scale up and
get top uh imagea accuracy at the time
of their
release so next we'll talk about Sim
clear which um um is very similar to
what we just covered with a small
change so we just talked about um
Moco where um they have this momentum on
part of their Network so Sim clear gets
rid of that but they make an additional
change and what they do is they add this
additional G network which
um predicts the feature Z that we're
trying to contrast against from our
representation so whereas in mocho we
directly used um our feature that we
contrasted against as our representation
here they're learning an additional
Network to map
that
so with this trick it turns out that you
don't actually need um the momentum
encoder uh process-wise it looks very
similar it's hard for me to show I think
without uh
yeah
effectively um the process looks the
exact same except now uh yeah the
process looks the exact same except now
because we have removed this asymmetry
with the momentum you can actually just
do things both ways you can take X1 or x
i and XJ and actually flip it as well um
and so that's what we see over here they
do one augmentation on the image process
it through the network take the second
augmentation process it through the
network and and then take the loss um
where they take the loss um both
ways so Sim clear was uh very effective
and able to outperform
Moco and um kind of remov this
additional complexity of the
momentum um I'll skip ahead
here so yeah that's this is kind of like
a more direct compar comparison of the
Sim clear approach versus the moo
approach um on the Sim clear is this
more complete endtoend approach where we
process these frames and are able to do
contrastive on everything in the current
batch whereas the momentum contrast lets
us pass less examples into the encoder
because we can keep a huge cue of
negative
examples um and the tradeoff I guess you
can think about as more of just like a
compute trade-off in terms of what
you're really able to have and we'll see
that Moco later on actually gets rid of
their own negative q and does something
more similar to sim clear um with better
compute because now we can just do
everything with the current
batch um I'll skip some of this because
of time so with Moco B3 um they they
State themselves that there's no nothing
extremely novel in what they're
proposing here they just give some
engineering tricks and um scale up to
using Vision Transformers which were
working very well at the time
um yeah I'll spare the details of the
code but effectively the main uh changes
that they make is they remove the
momentum or sorry they remove the
negative buffer and momentum is still
kept and um they replace the network
with a
vit so they notied that when scaling to
a vit you actually result in a lot of
instability and that's seen over here
where when we increase the batch size
you see all these blits in
training um this also happened
regardless of the learning
rate and they kind of proposed they they
when they were monitoring these um
training curves they noticed that these
gradient spikes would first happen in
the first layer of the network and then
a few steps uh a few training iterations
down the line would happen in the later
layers or the last layer of the
network and they hypothesized that that
this instability could be just due to um
like um yeah too much changes happening
up earlier in the network and then that
later propagating down the
line um and kind of and if you have
these gradient spikes you're effectively
like unlearning some of the features and
so their goal was to try to avoid that
and the way that they did that is
instead of having a learned patch
projection where when you take your
image patches in the viit you learn it
with um like a linear layer they just
use a random layer and they freeze that
so you can't learn that projection
anymore and so your representations into
the V are fixed and they find that just
fixes the issue um and now you no longer
have these uh training blips that's the
green curve showed here whereas the blue
curve over here has these training
blips um yeah and you can see that for
these larger learning rates we're able
to get pretty much higher performance
like two percentage points on image net
is uh pretty big for just this simple
change and this is a trick that down the
line other uh models will also use when
they find it
helpful um cool so the next model in
this line of work that we'll cover is bi
or bootstrap your own
latent uh the approach here looks very
similar to what we've been seeing where
you're taking two views of your same uh
image and then passing it to get a
representation and then we project it to
a new uh feature space what they're
doing in addition here is they're adding
an additional what they call a predic
Network um and then instead of doing a
contrastive loss they're actually
simplified it to using an L2
loss so now what after we pass our first
augmentation through the image uh we
normalize it we get our normalized Z and
we get our normalized Q from the uh
Target Network and then we can use an L2
loss over here um effectively this is
just a a coine distance loss now that
we've normalized things and again this
target network is um uh exponential
moving average version of our original
weights up
here
so um this seems nice because we're able
to
remove um the contrastive component now
we can just simply do this feature
prediction with an L2 loss and that
seems uh much easier than having to go
through all the complexity of having
like the info NC loss and it turns out
that that's it also seems to perform
much better as well so here's comparison
of using a resonet 50 encoder uh top one
image net accuracy is now at
74% um and if you scale that up to
resonet 200 we're able to get
um one other nice component of by is
that it seems to work well even with
smaller batch sizes so with Sim clear
one thing that that was the end end
approach that we were talking about
earlier with slear it seems that when
you reduce the B oops when you reduce
the batch size too low you get a massive
drop in performance that's what we kind
of show here if we go to two small batch
size we get a decrease of up to 4%
accuracy whereas the the decrease for by
that seems a bit more robust to
that
um and we see that b also seems more
robust to the amount of augmentations
that we're applying toward our
Imes so here's another perspective on
what B is doing so it seems weird that
we were able to magically get rid of the
contrastive loss yet the model was still
able to learn features that could be
predictive uh without being trivial like
one potential issue of removing the
contrastive loss is if you're not trying
to push away examples in your negatives
then um you can just map everything to
the same point in your feature space for
example if you map everything into zero
then um you can get perfect L2 loss but
then you haven't really learned any
useful
feature so
um oops so it's it's kind of weird that
b actually is able to do well and the
authors don't mention this or study this
exactly why in their work but I think
this is a pretty interesting intuition
which is what actually is being used is
in their MLP projection networks they
have have this batch Norm
um and what happens is you actually
remove this batch Norm from the Bol
prediction Network um performance
basically just drops to as if you were
using some completely random feature um
and if you actually investigate the
Learned feature z um it turns out that
it does collapse and it's just being map
to the same uh same point in the feature
space and so what's actually happening
when you're using this batch Norm it
turns out is it's probably doing some
type of like imp it contrastive learning
um and that batch Norm is probably
needed is what's needed to prevent this
mode claps because now um when your
features get mapped through the batch
Norm you're subtracting the mean and
then dividing by the standard deviation
and so everything gets kind of
renormalized back
out um and so you're comparing
essentially to the mean of everything in
your mini batch due to the batch
normalization in the network
itself so yeah here's just like a quick
summary of of the different methods
we've covered so far Sim clear does
everything end to end um there's no need
for any momentum but you generally you
will need a pretty big batch size um in
their MLP Network they actually use
batch
Norm um within the layer as well as at
the
output Moco looks very similar couple of
differences being the momentum that they
use for their target Network as well as
the memory bank the memory bank is
gotten rid of in Moco B3 and they just
use everything in the same batch like
simair but they still maintain the
momentum but with the momentum you can
see that you can get away with not
having any batch Norm in um the MLP or
sorry I mean we need the contrasted loss
for that batch Norm is different borm
yeah but they don't use bat Norm here
with Bol we see that they don't use the
contrasted L but they still have this
bat Norm here as well as the addition of
this additional prediction
nwor
so next um we'll talk about some
distillation methods which will look
very similar to what we've seen except
they will kind of try to get rid of the
contrastive loss and we can kind of see
B is already in that direction they
don't use a contrastive loss so maybe
it's it would be better to put theol in
this section technically um but these
type of approaches will aim towards
moving the contrasted
loss so uh dino is um one of the works
in line that produced very good
results so first let's consider
knowledge
distillation um you can consider
knowledge distillation as having some
teacher Network and then let's say you
pre-trained something on imag net and
you want to distill that into a student
Network U maybe you're trying to have a
smaller Network that can still get the
same performance as the teacher
Network so uh the way you can do that is
pretty simple you just go through all
the examples in your data set and you
try to have the student match the output
distribution of your
teacher
um so yeah we just Tred to minimize the
cross entropy between these two
distributions um which just looks like
how you would normally do but instead of
having like Z1 labels you would have the
labels from the teacher as
well
yeah sorry um I we haven't got to the
self-supervised part I was just trying
to introduce this idea of knowledge
distillation so like a more typical
example would be you have a frozen
teacher let's say you pre-trained it on
imet you get really good results but
let's say it's a resinet 2,000 or 200
and you want to have a resonet 50 that
can get the same performance you can try
to distill your smaller Network to
achieve the same performance as your
larger Network and so in this Cas your
then you just pass an images X into your
teacher and you have your student how to
match that distribution so this is like
a more typical place of where you have
like a knowledge distillation or for
example let's say you have a language
model you want your llama 7B to get the
performance of the 70b model you could
just take bunch of examples freeze the
7bb and then try to have the 7B model
match the same distribution as the
7 yeah in this in this uh in this
supervised setting
yeah that's a
typo thanks I will correct that or let's
just that
now
um
okay
so uh dino tries to take take this
approach but then apply it to a
self-supervised
setting the issue now comes as we don't
actually have a future network so we
don't have any the map to we only have
the network re tring to learn and
um um yeah so they they try to do some
tricks to get that to work but as you
can see kind of now we're back into this
very similar setting that we we saw
before where we have our image X and we
now apply are applying two different
augmentations to
it
um so the the path for the student side
happens in the same manner we pass our
image through the student G and then we
get some distribution over features
instead
of uh just a feature itself now now
we're treating these as
distributions the trick for how we get
our teacher is we're again going to use
an exponential moving average of our
student Network
and the intuition there is we want to
try to stabilize what the teacher
network is we don't want the teacher
distribution to be moving too much we
want to have that relatively be
stationary of course it's being updated
as the student learns more but it's
going to be more stationary compared to
the
student and um yeah we're going to apply
this uh we'll ignore this centering part
for now but then we'll produce some
distribution and then we want to try to
match those distributions as with um the
knowledge distillation
so here again just like with um with B
we have nothing really to prevent
collapse
and that's yeah and and and that's where
the centering Parts come in and so
what's happening in this centering is
you subtract out the mean um to kind of
reenter your
distribution and uh you can see in the
pseudo code we have our augmentation our
two augmentations of our image X we pass
them through the student and teacher and
then we apply the cross entropy loss
over here our knowledge distillation
loss and then
update but then we have oh yeah so and
we also do the poly averaging for our
teacher parameters and then we have this
additional C which is um our the way
that we Center the
distribution um and the way that we
Center the distribution is we look at a
history of the features from the teacher
and we create an exponential moving
average of those
features so um that written out kind of
looks something like this we have our
image and we apply these two
augmentations to it um we get these
distributions from both sides of the
network and then we try to minimize this
uh across
entropy and this centering step is
important to prevent mode collapse
and after this training uh procedure you
they can they apply to a Vari wide
variety of different tasks we'll just
look at a few um so for example you can
get these nice segmentations um
completely unsupervised the way that
they do this is they just look at the
attention mask and they threshold it on
the CLS token and then they compare some
similarity to a ground tree
mask and you can see that Dino is able
to actually pay a lot more attention to
objects within the scene compared to a
supervised vit
Network um with linear and K nearest
neighbors classification on image net
you can also see that Doo is performing
quite well with 75% linear probe
accuracy um with resinet 50 if you're
using a bit version um it's able to get
even a little bit higher with
77% you can also they also looked at
these um saliency Maps looking at the
self attention for a variety of
reference points um and you can see that
it's paying attention to semantically
similar Parts um in the
scene and able to pay good attention to
like objectness and kind of ignore
background
um yeah maybe it's helpful to look at
some differences of dyo compared to
these prior methods that um we've looked
at so cross entropy is the loss that we
saw that we were using earlier in order
to do the matching but you could imagine
that you could potentially also use MSE
loss um turns out if you use MSE loss
you actually get a reasonable drop in
performance and so uh having this oops
having this distillation loss is pretty
important um if you remove momentum you
can see that that instantly results in
collapse um and so having a more stable
teacher is very
important so with iBot they took this
idea that they that people were using in
dyo and they thought if we're trying to
find the distribution of just the
features of the image can we also do it
at like a more granular level can we do
it at a patch level
um and that's exactly what they do
so for each uh augmentation of the image
you have your online tokenizer or your
online Network taken all the features
and then you have your student Network
take a Patchi Patchi version of the
images and when you pass it through the
network you just like before try to do
the distillation on the at the Image
level by applying the feature on the CLS
token of the viit but then you can also
apply the same loss but on the uh on the
p patches of or the patches that you
passed into the student so the student
will have a certain amount of patches
that were placed here there's some that
have been masked out but you can try to
match it with the full version that the
teacher um has seen and the teacher got
to see all of the patches so now you're
trying to effectively um
learn a feature that can be predictive
of something that has seen of of a
features that have seen the entire
image
um and this trick enables you to
outperform dyo um and scale well getting
up to
81% image net uh linear probe
accuracy
um we'll just quickly glean over Dino V2
but effectively they take the idea of
iBot and add a bunch of other tricks and
able to further push performance um and
you're able to get uh even better G uh
these type visualizations and and um
this is a visualization
of the first principal components of um
the output
features um and you're able to do these
very nice self-supervised tasks as well
as use it as pre-training for further
Downstream tasks like segmentation and
depth
prediction so in the next line of work
that we'll talk about is JEA so
in JEA this approach that Yan Lun
proposed in his paper um in 2020 or
2022 uh this paper is really big and it
proposes kind of yon's thoughts on the
path yeah like a huge proposal on
various different types of machine
learning and how to build one really big
cohesive system so JEA is only very
small part of it it's not the entire
part um but effectively what he's saying
here is that he believes believes that
the way that we should be doing
unsupervised future prediction is
by uh so there different ways that we've
seen us to do the self-supervised
learning so far and the way that Yan Lon
thinks that is most promising is we take
our image X pass it through our encoder
um and instead of directly predicting y
we want to predict um in this Lane
feature space so we we passed both our X
and our Y into some latent space and
then we try to predict uh Y in this
latent space the lat yeah we try to
predict the Laten space version of Y um
from the Laten space version of X so one
motivating example is for example let's
say x is um a video clip of a
car um these Laten space representations
might be like semantics of the car
position and the car
velocity um and then maybe the
prediction is
and we want to predict the future Laten
space but we don't really if we were
trying to do in BL pixel space we might
have to worry about semantic or lowlevel
details um and kind of maybe that might
lose out on some of the SYM metics but
ideally our encoder is only paying
attention to the symmetrically relevant
information and so that means we would
hopefully only need to pay attention to
like the car position and car velocity
rather than focus on smaller level
details like how the leaves in the
background are
moving um
yeah
[Music]
uh yes let me MO head to here maybe this
will make more sense
um so what we've seen with the
contrastive learning so far is it looks
something like this this joint embed
production let's say Moco or Sim clear
we have our image X we pass it through
some encoder and we get some feature and
then we try to do like cross entropy for
example or uh contrastive learning for
example um in these generative
architectures for example let's say vae
that we've seen we first have or Mae we
first take our image X we encode it
um then we pass it through a decoder to
try to recover the original image X or
yeah the original image or the original
something and it for example this could
also be like a class I mean he he tried
to formulate this in a general example
but in the in in the case that we're
looking at just say that these are both
instances of the same image or
augmentations of the same image
um and what the this joint embedding
prediction architecture is saying is
we pass it everything is being passed
into this lat in space like in
a um but we addition have this like
additional predictor Network that is
trying to predict on top of our X so we
try to do some additional prediction on
top of what was given but we can
potentially condition on additional lat
variables to try to model
uncertainty uh Z is like a random
variable yeah
do that make sense or kind
of so so maybe one other way to see this
is if we looked way back to uh the
comparison between like Moco or Sim
clear versus bol bol had an additional
prediction head on top of the future
space and you can see that as um
effectively what what Yan Lun would call
call like the predictor over here so you
just have like an additional head that
you're predicting off of in the simplest
case
sorry um Z in here is just a random
variable that you can potentially
condition on they don't actually use it
here um but you can just treat it as
additional noise to model like a
distribution if there's
uncertainty so yeah in this paper I JEA
they try to take this type of approach
and then apply it to learning
self-supervised features from
images
um specifically what they're doing
is you have yeah so now again remember
we're in this situation where we have
some X and some Y in this case X is what
is called context and Y is called this
Target and what we want to do is we want
to try to predict the embedded features
of our or we want to try to predict the
embedded features of our Target from uh
embedded features of our context plus
some predictor
Network so we have a common context
encoder which in this case is um a vit
Network which takes patches of the
image
and uh we yeah we produce those feature
representations um and then now we want
to try to predict at these so so this is
this gray box over here we pass through
on COD we get our uh gray features for
that part of the image and now we want
to try to predict these parts in the
Target um and the way that they
represent this is that they represent
these as mass
tokens so they pass that the cont this
context as well as their Mass tokens to
get predicted features oops predicted
features from the target encoder and
then they apply and L2 loss across these
different
features so this should look similar to
Bol but then they've kind of structured
the task a little bit differently as
well as like the architectures and stuff
that they're
using um so here are an examples of how
they construct their context and their
targets so they first construct their
targets by taking the original image and
they uh sample these random blocks in
the
image uh then they essentially sample
random blocks for the context and then
subtract out the one so there's no
overlapping blocks and you effectively
get that as your context that um they
use and that's how they construct these
training
pairs so if you train your model with
this procedure on a large data set um
you're able
to um get very computationally efficient
results
and so what they're showing here is the
number of GPU pre-training hours versus
top 1% image net
evaluation and one advantage of a type
of approach like this compared to
something like Mae is you don't actually
need to do reconstruction which means
that everything is operating your lane
space which means that it could
potentially be a lot more
computationally efficient as
well um so yeah we see good performance
over here despite being only trained for
300 epox compared to me which is let's
say being trained for
160 1,600
um another thing that they can do here
is they can try to even though we did
the pre-training in latent space we can
try to learn a model that does
reconstruction given the ENC encoded
latent um so this is done after the
pre-training step and effectively um
they learn a conditional diffusion model
um which tries to learn how to do
diffusion based on these learned
representations um and these are the
representations that you see over here
you can see that it's able to
effectively capture that there's a bird
here kind of its location um how it
should be posed um but it kind of
doesn't pay attention to things like
background detail um like yeah what what
color the background should be uh same
thing with um the dog over here you can
see that the pose and everything of the
dog is very correct um even if maybe
some the smaller details and stuff are
missing and so that that information is
at least uh present in the
representation so V JEA is a followup
which was just released two is weeks ago
I think um and they they apply the exact
same idea but in the video space I think
due to time I'll just skip over it but
if you all are interested um the details
are
there um so next we'll talk about clip
so
clip um kind of opened us up to this age
of um self-supervised learning using
text to image
pairs um and I'm sure you all know of
clip but um this is how they uh actually
did it so just like
before um we want to take two we have
some X and some y but instead of being
an augmentation of the same image
they're actually different modalities of
of a pair so we have image and its
corresponding text pair and then we're
going to apply our um contrastive
objective where we try to classify
the correct text with the correct image
uh and vice versa and all the other
examples in the batch are treated as
negative examples we want to have that
feature try to be different
um um
and once you have this pre-training
objective hopefully your feature is very
your your image features and your text
features are very good at um are very
aligned which lets you hopefully do
something like Downstream classification
very easily in a zero shot Manner and
how you would do that is let's say we're
trying to do imet classification we can
take all of our imag net classes and
then create a text label for it for
example we have like playing car dog
here and then we can make a caption a
photo of a dog um and then try to
contrast these text labels against the
feature from our image
encoder um so at the time of clip there
weren't that many any really good open
uh text image data sets um in their
paper they mentioned that there was this
one YC yfcc 1 million 100 million but
they mentioned that there's a lot of
pretty lowquality captions from the
metadata in that data set like like this
is one of the captions for the data set
which obviously doesn't contain any
semantically meaningful information um
so they ended up and constructing their
own data set of 400 million image text
pairs um which is proprietary and they
did this with some like
search uh uh automated searches with
some generated
queries the code and implementation for
for clip is very simple you just have
some image encoder um some viit and some
text
encoder and you pass that through for
all your images and your text and then
you get these corresponding features
normalize them um and then you get dot
product you apply dot product to get
your logits and then you just apply
cross entropy and you apply it both ways
so yeah then this lets you have
um really uh really impressive at the
time zero shot um capabilities for
classification so they tested it on a
whole wide variet uh range of different
classification tasks on the right here
is
showing um zero shot clip compared to a
fully supervised linear
Baseline and you can see that that their
zero shot based line is able to do
better than if you do like a fully
supervised version of
course it's not exactly comparable this
is only a fully supervised version of a
linear classifier fitted on the raw data
um but still it shows that uh this
pre-training is very
effective um cool so in addition Beyond
just its usefulness in um zero shot
classification it can actually be a very
useful feature for Downstream models so
so we saw earlier in unclip um that you
can use the pre-trained text encoder to
get those uh text features that we can
then use to condition on for image
Generation Um and we see a lot of uh vlm
models today Vision language models we
actually use a pre-trained clip model to
encode the um image into some amount of
tokens and then that's pass into the
language model
um so yeah these these features are
useful in in other settings as
well
um okay I will skip over CP and and
since then there's been lots of um
different uh extensions of clip just
because of how useful the model is so
one that I think is quite interesting is
this one called
flip uh again from kaiming uh atair he's
the last author on this one so the the
obser this was done after Mee and his
observation there was with Mee like this
masking is a very effective strategy in
terms of speeding up computation you
only need to do computation on your
unmasked
patches um and so the thought was if you
can apply this type of strategy to clip
training in some sense and see if that
improves
things um and you can see the the
benefit over here so over here in Gray
is if you just apply the normal clip or
their clip reproduction
then if you apply 50% masing strategy on
the image you get this learning curve um
the the y axis is image net 1 uh linear
prob
accuracy um and if you apply 70% masking
you get this uh learning curve over here
and so you can see that you're able to
get one you're able to train much more
efficiently um if you're looking at this
same final performance you're able to
get like a 3.7x speed up time and for
the same amount of training hours you're
able to get much higher
performance
so
um one thing that you do have to be
careful of if you do do this is that
there is some train and test time
mismatch because in train time we're
masking parts of the image but at test
time we want to see the full image and
so what they do mention is you have to
do this unmasked fine-tuning where after
you do your pre-training for I believe
it's like3 Epoch you do a full end to
end fine tuning with uh seeing the full
full image um it matters most for if
you're doing a very high masking ratio
for 75% for example you see this huge
gap here um it matters less if you're
using a smaller mask ratio like
50 um
so we've we've covered a large variety
of different methods so you might ask if
there's any ways we can combine these
methods um slip is one approach that
does this um done by Norman here also uh
at
Berkeley and um yeah the idea is quite
simple let's try to um add on some
self-supervised learning on top of clip
to see if the self-supervised learning
objectives are able to
help so uh slip is their method shown
over here and you're able to get a
5% uh boost in terms of the zero shot
performance if you apply some
self-supervised learning
losses um
with pure self super Vision there is no
zero shot capability so it's not shown
here and with linear classification you
see that there's um a benefit as well on
top of clip or just using pure
self-supervised
learning um the algorithm is pretty
straightforward um they're using Sim
clear as their self-supervised learning
uh approach here so again we have our
two augmentations because we need that
for our self-supervised learning
approach um we uh embed these features
to get our uh predicted values or our
our latent value Z and then we can apply
just the normal Sim clear loss and the
normal clip loss and add them up
together and that's shown over here on
the
right uh and we can see that that helps
um across a wide range of different
architectures as well and scales
correspondingly um across viit small uh
base and large size mod
mod um the next one I'll quickly cover
is cocow uh contrasted captioners are
also image text Foundation
models um what they do here is they
apply this captioning task to try to
learn an image encoder and a text
encoder and they're actually able to
achieve a top uh 1% accuracy
state-ofthe-art 91% this was a
state-ofthe-art for quite a bit of time
I think it's been taken over now now
um um but yeah this is this is very
good um okay I'll skip over the yeah so
essentially the idea is very
simple first we're going to do the
contrastive loss like we did with clip
so that's what's shown here we pass the
image we get some CLS token feature um
same thing with the text and we do
contrasted loss in addition we're going
to have this multimodal decoder head
which is going to try to recaption the
image so with clip we just had this
caption um but now we can apply a shiy
version um and do next token prediction
to also try to predict the caption given
just the
image and they find that yeah this is
able to get really good results on a
huge uh variety of different
benchmarks um let's see how much time do
we
have
um okay I will skip over the these um
but there there are some other
interesting approaches that people took
um if you all are interested to take a
look
later so um next I'm going to briefly
cover different ways that we can use
self-supervised learning in
reinforcement learning and
control
so uh the first one this was done by
Arvin who is one of the original
instruct instructors of this course um
curl contrast of unsupervised
representation for reinforcement
learning so architecturally we'll see
something very similar that we've seen
before with the contrasted methods where
we have our observation and we have our
um two separate uh feature encoders that
we are applying our contrastive loss
to um but again remember now we're
trying to do some Downstream
reinforcement learning
and uh we take the features Q from our
encoder and we do normal reinforcement
learning on those
features so for example if we cross out
this reinforcement learning pipeline it
would just be normal contrastive
learning and if we cont cross out this
contrastive learning part would just be
normal reinforcement
learning um the motivation here being
that potentially this unsupervised
objective can help us get more bits and
more information um learning wise for
our Downstream
RL
so yeah the approach is very similar I'm
not going to cover the RL because that's
out of scope for this course but we can
talk about how the unsupervised learning
helps the downstream RL
process um so here the augmentation that
they find most helpful is crop they
tried a bunch of different other
augmentations um and as we were talking
about before the the downstream task
actually matters and so a lot of these
more color based stuff at least for this
type of task in in these simulated maoko
environments doesn't really matter um
but maybe caring about more spatial
relationships actually matters so crop
is the one that they were using um they
were
using um again cross entropy loss and
then they tested um a couple of
different settings so one is to use the
exponential moving average or without um
again we need that exponential moving
average to get good
performance um and then there's using of
the of what what type of loss to use in
the distance metric so there's the B
linear versus direct or using direct
coine distance and bilinear uh is also
quite helpful
here so on the left over here is running
kurl versus sack sack is the base
algorithm that they base on and kurl is
adding the representation learning on
top um so State Sac is just using the
raw underlying state of the environment
whereas curl in red is training from raw
pixels um and what you see over here is
that the one with curl is able to match
the gray curve um almost for all of the
environments and that's pretty
impressive because curl actually doesn't
have the access to underlying State and
so you're able to essentially match the
ground truth State information uh
performance by just looking at the
pixels and um here's corresponding
performance on comparing to a couple of
other different algorithms and you can
see that curl is able to perform
competitively in this setting as
well so next we'll look at r3m
so the motivation of r3m
is we want to look for robotic
manipulation we want to have some type
of pre-trade visual
representation um a common strategy in
robotics is to take a pre-trained uh res
net on image net and then use those
features um but of course those reset
features are trained on like trying to
do random classification and so might
not pay attention to the certain
features that we care about for Robotics
and so maybe if we uh think about the
data and the pre-training we can get a
better representation for the types of
Robotics tasks we care
about so what are the types of things
that we might care about one is temporal
dynamics of the scene so hopefully our
representation should be somehow
knowledgeable about how States
transition to other states um another
important feature might be how relevant
uh are pay attention to things that are
semantically relevant to various tasks
that we might care about such as objects
and their relationships to each
other and um another one is just to be
compact so the data and the the the
process that they use here is that
they're going to use e 4D as their
pre-training
data and uh an advantage of this is it
has a lot of inth wild data that's
entric viewed and it has language
annotations as well um it has a large a
variety of different uh yeah lots of
video data from very diverse
locations um so again we're going to
apply this idea of contrastive learning
but in a slightly different way so what
they're doing over here is they're doing
time contrastive learning and they're
encoding temporal Dynamics into the
representation um we can you don't have
to look into the loss too closely I'll
just explain the intuition but effective
what we want is we want frames that are
closer together um
to have a representation um that is
close to each other so we want this to
be a positive pair and we want um some
frame that's very far away from our
anchor to uh be a negative pair um and
that's effectively how they decide to
choose what's a positive and what's a
negative
pair the other one is to have um video
language alignments so these videos are
at with the language of what the a
language action of what is happening in
that video
segment and again this alignment should
oh yeah and the intuition here is we
want the alignment to increase over the
course of the video if we're doing some
action hopefully that language
annotation should be more accurate the
further we get into the video
um
and um as well as the frame the language
should match with the current video but
should be far away from uh other
different videos um and again we can
apply the a contrastive like objective
to achieve
that um then we just throw all those
terms together in our loss and then we
apply some regularization as well so
those L1 and L2 regularization to
encourage some types of
scarcity um the downstream pass that
they test on is just imitation learning
uh imitation learning you can just think
of you have the ground truth State as
well as the action and um they attest
across these wide variety of different
environments and these are their
baselines so mocho which we saw earlier
um mocho and we we have clip
representations we have image net
supervised representations we have
representations trained from scratch and
you can see that they're able to that
these um r3m representations are able to
do much better on these robotics tasks
um Loco 345 just means that they're
taking the intermediary features at
those um Parts those I think like the
third to last fourth to last and fifth
to last
layers um so we saw these types of
contrastive type objectives being
used um can we use one of these
reconstruction type objectives that um
Peter was talking about
earlier um so that's what was done in
this mask visual pre-training for motor
control paper done by Titan Ilia up
ly the idea is to try to apply Mee to
learn features for robotic control and
they have a procedure that's very
similar to Mee where they're taking a
large video data set of uh entric hand
Focus type data that is has a lot of
object interaction that might be more
relevant to Robotics and uh pre-training
and Mee on that then Downstream they're
taking those representations from their
encoder this Frozen encoder and then
trying to learn a policy on top of
that um the specifics we don't have to
get into detail um this is the data the
data set combination they did they did
epic kitens YouTube 10 days at hand
something
something something to
something and uh they create this
Benchmark which is essentially just a
collection of a variety of different
robotics tasks um and they they train
out their all their policies using po
um and yeah this figure is a little bit
small but effectively you can see that
um MVP is their model um this one in
Orange is using Oracle ground truth
State and then um yellow
is um scratch supervised and you can see
that that pre-training with the MVP MVP
features helps increase performance by a
lot getting pretty close to the Oracle
policy which which has access to the
ground TR um
[Music]
States
um so another potential issue that we
have in robotics is that we have a large
variety of different data that has a
large different um that has many
different modalities um sometimes we
might have only video data and we don't
have actually the corresponding video
trajectory or the actions that go with
those and so advantageous to like learn
a representation that could leverage all
these different data
sets so that's what we did in this paper
MTM
um in MTM we first take our a bunch of
trajectory data and trajectories can
just be thought of as a multimodal
sequence of um a multimodal sequence of
a variety of different elements uh we
might have States we might have actions
we might have um vision
values um and so we flatten that into a
common embedding
space um in specifically we just looked
at simulated environments for this um we
have States rewards and actions as our
different
modalities um and if we have missing
modalities in our data set then we can
just treat that as like a force
mask um and then we have and then we can
train similarly with the Mae type
objective where we randomly mask out
Parts in our sequence and then try to
reconstruct those missing
parts so in this paper we explore a
variety of different things but uh I'll
only talk about the state representation
one which is the one relevant to um this
portion of the
lecture so the procedure is effectively
we pre-train with some random masking
using an me type of approach on these
trajectory level
data and then Downstream we try to test
how well these representations work and
that's what's being done here so the
setup is we have some offline data set
of the robot doing a variety of
different things and um we pre-train on
these
trajectories we then run a uh RL
algorithm on these uh learned
representations and compare that to
learning an RL algorithm on the raw
States um and with these RL algorithms
sometimes you need the states but
sometimes you need like States and
actions and so we can also jointly embed
the state action pairs using our feature
extractor so the green is the base
feature extractor orange is using um
fine-tuned and then purple is using the
state action features and you can see
that uh we're able to get better than
the state the the raw feature based one
and sometimes even beat what the ASM
totically trained State or the oxm
totically trained um um approach is able
to get
so next I'll talk about this work uh
Mass World models for visual control
this is work led by yungo done at his
time in
Berkeley um so so the base of this
approach is um
dreamer um and we won't talk about
dreamer but just so you all know what's
going under the hood there's two
components one is this world model where
you're trying to learn
how your future states are affected by
actions and then the other is a policy
learning aspect where you use this world
model to try to like learn a policy uh
the details you can read the paper if
you're interested in this type of
Direction The Innovation that uh yio had
here is that let's try to decouple the
representation learning from the
Dynamics learning so in in this type of
approach we try to learn the
representation as well as learn the the
Dynamics of these representations but
potentially we can try to like decouple
that uh in and and that that might make
things more
efficient um so that's what's done here
in this visual representation learning
phase shown on the left and then
correspondingly we will then do Dynamics
learning on these extracted features um
from our learned Auto encoder and and
the structure setup that we have is um
again another mass auto encoder style
structure where we will
learn this feature representation
through reconstructing of random masks
um
specifically they make a couple of Y
makes a couple of changes here that are
actually quite important the first one
is to pass the original image through
some com layers first um and we'll talk
about why that's important and then in
the uh reconstruction space we're also
going to pass in a mass token for the
reward because we want and we're going
to reconstruct R the reward as well idea
here being that hopefully our state
maintains the information that lets us
like predict the the reward that was
assigned to this
state um this top part is this new
representation learning loss the bottom
part is the original uh World model loss
again uh the the math you can all look
at if you're interested on your own and
so this is the corresponding uh
results uh the top sequence of images is
the ground truth sequence of
images the this one is the reconstructed
version um using mass World models we
have a predicted version which is you
effectively roll out in in your world
model space and try to see
um um the the corresponding images of
what it will look like and the bottom is
predicted from dreamer and in this case
it's kind of hard to see but there's
this like little apple that the robot is
trying to move um and you can see that
the apple is present here in the robot
with mass World models but you see it's
actually not present here in in dreamer
and what's happening is that dreamer
kind of is paying attention to these
pixel level features um that are more
heavily present in the image but kind of
forgets about this to model this smaller
like less relevant feature of this apple
um and it turns out that this reward
prediction component and the
convolutional feature component helps
the model pay attention more to these
features um the convolutional component
kind of allows the features that you
passed before into the Mae to have
greater context and so it's able to kind
of um if you have a very small object
like this object uh this Cube that
you're trying to pay attention to it can
help uh allow the model to pay more
attention to these uh smaller pixel wise
elements in your
image so yeah M model is able to perform
the base algorithm you can see the blue
curve is able to outperform these down
here um and again here is the ablation
on using the com feature so if you
remove the com feature um oops if you
remove the com com feature you see that
you're actually not able to do that well
actually dreamer works better but adding
those few convolutional features before
um you pass it into the me
reconstruction objective helps a
lot um so uh Peter briefly mentioned
this before but now we'll do the Mast uh
multiv view
Mee and in this setting
um and Robotics is a setting where we
oftentimes have to deal with multiple
cameras that are looking so in in this
case we might have an egocentric camera
of the robot looking at the object as
well as like a third person camera um
this was
from um yeah and this is like a robot
hand that we have a bunch of different
cameras that are looking over the
hand
so with Mee um the nice part about the
Transformer is that we can deal with
everything in raw token space and then
like the encoder decoder doesn't care
what the tokens actually are um and so
we can map now two images both views the
wrist camera and the overhead view into
um the token space and try to do
reconstruction just like with the prior
paper it was very helpful to have
convolutional features first before pfy
and passing into the
encoder
and yeah the idea main idea here is to
reconstruct Mass viewpoints um to learn
cross view information so hopefully now
we can
predict from given let's say parts of um
the risk view we should be able to
predict what the third person camera
view looks like as you can see over here
here we completely masked out this other
View and so hopefully that lets us learn
maybe more robust representation since
the the model should be able to learn
features um
yeah that that can reconstruct um from
different
views and
downstream we um Downstream we can now
apply this model a few different ways
one is we can use the encoder just to
encode both views but it might be that
Downstream we only have like a single
view um and so we can train the model on
just a single view version of that um a
single viewed version of the
environment um so here's the performance
um if
you so if you use the multiple views you
can see that that's helpful but maybe um
but we trained it in this multi view so
maybe like that multi view pre-training
is helping it in this multi view setting
um this other experiment is we only give
it a single control view from the front
and we use our pre-trained encoder and
we can see that we're able to get still
outperform the other methods actually
get more than double than um without
um so let's
see so another
potential issue that we have in robotics
is that we have to put cameras attached
to the robot sometimes people move your
cameras and then your policy no longer
works so it' be very advantageous to
train a really robust policy that can
work across a large range of different
viewpoints and we can apply this multi
viw Mee idea to the setting where we can
generate um a bunch of different
views and then use the same like multi
view uh Master World model training
approach so Step One is we do this
representation with Viewpoint
randomization instead of having just the
wrist camera and the overview camera
we're going to randomize these different
viewpoints um and then we learn using
our RL algorithm on the features from
this learned
encoder and downstream we can apply we
can see how this apply how well this
model is able to apply when we apply a
bunch of randomizations to um our camera
views and and we're able to see that
this multi view approach is able to
outperform Prior
approaches um and here is a real world
example of that where now this robot
which is only taking in camera images is
Rob bust to all these different
augmentations of how we're actually
holding the camera so despite the fact
that you know we're shaking the camera
around a lot we're moving it around a
lot um the policy is still robust to to
these
changes um cool so I think I will end
lecture here um we have some small
components that I left in the slides
with regards to language models but
we're going to have a language model
dedicated lecture next week so I think
it's okay if we don't uh fully cover
these um so yeah
thanks